et bien bonjour bienvenue dans ce
diagonale tv spéciale championnats du
monde camille topalov pour la deuxième
partie avec elle on relance bonjour
bonjour stéphane bonjour à tous donc
effectivement championnat du monde
complètement dramatique pour le banc
avec un deuxième résultat surprenant
surprenant on va pas dévoiler tout de
suite aux résultats on va on va voir
cette partie mais déjà la première
partie c'était c'était quand même une
demi surprise quand il kramnik il ya la
première partie on s'attendait un peu
peut-être à ça c'est à dire que tombent
à l'eau prend énormément de risques joue
jusqu'au bout ne veut pas signer de
l'une des nuls sans jouer mais en face
ses chroniques et limitera n'y pas si
ble ment en passe en caisse le point est
ce que est ce que ton club a réussi à
revenir dans ce match tout de suite
c'est ce qui serait un résultat
extrêmement surprenants ah oui non alors
ce serait pas du tout surprenant qu'on
le mot comme on l'a déjà dit dans
l'émission précédente et aux panneaux
fait un joueur qui commence mal qui
chute dans certains tournois mais
longtemps à chauffer et puis ensuite qui
est capable d'enchaîner les victoires
c'est à dire que c'est pas un joueur
qu'il enchaîne une bonne fin de course
alors qu'il peut nier trois parties clic
quatre parties de suite et cela contre
les meilleurs joueurs du monde il a pas
fait contre vladimir kramnik parce que
vladimir kramnik ne joue pas beaucoup de
temps donc on sait pas trop ces deux
joueurs qui ne sont pas encore trop
rencontre et ils n'ont pas joué trop de
partis ensemble
donc c'est un bon c'est parce que c'est
un beau match d'ailleurs parce que d'un
côté on a fait venir kramnik barres
d'acier super solide qui perd
pratiquement jamais qu'abattu kasparov
dans un match en 14 parties avec deux
victoires 0 défaite
et en face on a total of qui est un peu
le psychopathe du jeu le joueur qui
envoie tout il met toutes les pièces à
l'attack jamais de compromis
jamais deux nuls toujours joué pour le
gain à free à quand il est moins bien il
continua et cédric gasnier très punchy
il peut transposer dans des positions un
peu inférieur où il assure en dépend
mais il ne le fait jamais est-ce qu'on
pourrait pas dire faire un top topaloff
est l'héritier de fisher et kasparov et
peut-être kramnik plutôt de petroci
arrêt car parfois on pourrait dire ça
mais je crois que t'as pas l'offre
je pense vraiment que c'est un joueur
atypique qu'on a jamais vu quoi on n'a
jamais vu se profile la c1 en tout cas
ce niveau là oui on a vu des joueurs qui
jouent toujours à fond pour le gain mais
pas de temps à dormir dans mon
appartement mondiale ou le où le risque
est plus peut-être à 8 h à narbonne
comme quand on fait plus cher on a des
mecs comme l'admirent cramique qui
exploitent la moindre imprécision qui
sont experts en défense mais qui perd
très peu de paris qui perd presque
jamais qui joue en contre bas évidemment
rien quand on envoie tout comme la
tendance des échecs en général c'est de
faire nul est bien en général celui
qu'elle prend plus de risques et ne
finit par le regretté voilà donc on va
voir dans cette émission c'est le
deuxième partie extraordinaire vous
allez voir vraiment une partie fantastic
deuxième partie de ce grand match
topalov cette fois les blancs avant de
passer à cette partie on va parler un
peu ternes altérée si vous êtes abonné à
tiago intérêts bien vous recevez cette
émission vous êtes alerter vous recevez
cette émission automatiquement et ce
pour toute une année alors peut-être on
peut parler de cet abonnement et loi
quel avantage peut s'abonner à diagonale
tv actualité pour les accueillir mais je
suppose que comme tout abonnement
l'avantagé principal c'est le prix ouais
c'est le prix évidemment tu veux on
obtient un prix de groupe mais je crois
qu'on me permet de gagner soit plus de
50% puis on va faire plus probable en
plus de 30 des missions dans l'année et
sur le prix à la demande l'abonnement
donne droit à toutes les années sont
passées toutes les émissions dans toute
émission à partir de l'abonnement votre
abonnement télévisuel
ça ressemble à la mononucléose ce genre
de choses donc à partir du jour de
l'abonnement puisqu'il ya deux vidéos
offertes aussi et il y aura des cadeaux
évidemment pour les abonnés ça c'est
certain il y aura des cadeaux tout au
long de l'année doit certainement des
évidemment les abonnés
donc comme tout abonné encourage le
projet de la télé oui en plus moi même
rassurant pour les produits exactement
voilà en vous abonnant dès mon intérêt
aussi vous contribuer au succès de
l'émission
alors c'est la bonne pour des monnaies
telle actualité l'actrice est normal
qu'un abonnement puisque bon c'est assez
régulier se prennent et ses côtés de
seriat de zotti de mission il ya les
événements non mais ça c'est particulier
c'est c'est en fonction des événements
qui ont lieu cette année il ya des
grands prix prévus ou diagonales tv
devrait filmer l'ensemble des matches
comme ça c'est un peu ma part et il ya
aussi des leçons et là on va parler de
d'échec l'académie alors avant d'arriver
rester sur l'échec a dit on va d'abord
montré le site du journal tv
voilà si on peut si on peut le voir
voilà ces diagonales tv.com des moniales
avec un e léo un téléphone comme voilà
donc vous avez toutes les émissions qui
sortent
y compris d'ailleurs des anciennes
émissions elles sont régulièrement mises
à jour sur le site
son sont commentés on va essayer aussi
dans le futur de commenter le stock le
stock des missions etc vous pouvez vous
abonner on vous conseille de vous
abonner à la newsletter de diagonale tb
qui est qui est importante pour avoir
les informations sur sur les nouveautés
et aussi sur l'édition sur les
événements entre sur les événements
aussi on fait surtout sur tout ce qui
peut concerner la télé est donc
parions qu'on le voit ici sur le site il
ya des grilles tv leçons alors le
dernier tiers de son ca part parce que
là c'est la volonté de constituer un
catalogue complet avaient toutes les
leçons possibles imaginables sur les
grands thèmes du jeu d'échec c'est à
dire évidemment d'abord les règles de
base évidemment les maths alimentaire
mais aussi évidemment les ouvertures les
milieux deux parties et les finales des
grands thèmes du jeu d'échecs
effectivement aux échecs vont effet
s'est pas laissée pas les grands thèmes
qui manquent énormément littérature
écrite il ya beaucoup beaucoup de sujets
à aborder donc c'est l'idée de ce
déconnade leçon c'est de regrouper par
thème puisque l'actualité on se laisse
guider par la partie d'actualité
justement
fouace et de la taille des fois c'est de
la défense des foyers un peu d'ouverture
mais ça reste un ensemble global
regardez toute une partie en revanche
diagonale de son c'est beaucoup plus
structuré c'est à dire qu'effectivement
stéphane comme tu l'as dit il y aura des
ouvertures pour les blancs pour les
noirs par répertoire par code de seo
éventuellement il y aura des finales
donc finale l'option finale deux tours
les maths élémentaire donc tout ça va
être structuré en modules de 26 minutes
et s'est fait donc en partenariat en fin
de séance une coproduction avec le site
échec académique on va montrer contre si
tu as les commandes à l'écran échec avec
cannes est tirée academy.com donkey et
co producteur de cette émission
diagonale la leçon et qui est notamment
animé par le grand maître international
gmi chabanon oui jean luc shahbanou qui
met beaucoup d'énergie pour écrire des
articles pour pour faire des leçons en
texte ils seront complémentaires des
vidéos bien entendu c'est à dire faudra
voir les vidéos plus les leçons un texte
avec ça vous avez toute une panoplie de
choses qui vous permettront
d'appréhender bien les passes du jeu
d'échecs et alors avec aussi la par
exemple la possibilité de voir quelques
blitz a enregistré la soirée loi qui a
fait 1 8 sur son plein chez ce qui a été
enregistré comme ça c'est des choses
aussi qu'enfin général qui seront
indisponibles aussi soir diagonale bon
là ça c'est un petit test cours un blitz
de cinq minutes enregistrée sur pied de
chaise commenter en direct petit contenu
sympathique à regarder ça peut détendre
ça dure cinq minutes et c'est plutôt
plutôt agréable à regarder
voilà donc donc voilà possibilité ici
aussi donc sur l'échec a dit me donc là
ce que ne fait pas du tout mtv qui est
concentré sur la vidéo exclusivement
mécanique permet au dessus des cours
particuliers
donc ça vraiment intéressant puisque
vous pouvez avec internet
eh bien à voir avec des logiciels comme
skype qui permet d'écouter enfin d'avoir
quelqu'un au téléphone gratuit en fait
donc d'avoir un grand maître au bout du
fil ou un grand joueur un peu importe
qui vous donne un cours
donc complet ça c'est une sorte de
télétravail il ya des outils structuré
pour ça notamment avec les chefs
l'animateur que montrer des coûts m des
flèches éclairer les cases et ont même
pensé commentée par skype
ça marche très très bien donc ça y est
proposée sur échec academy.com la
possibilité d'avoir des cours
particuliers avec des promesses d'achat
voilà donc terminée sur sur cette sas au
petit rappel des possibilités des offres
sur des mots tv j'étais pas à vous
abonner c'est aussi un acte de soutien
mais c'est aussi je pense un achat
prendre intéressant plus de 30 vidéos
par an même problème en 43 50 pour 60
euros
je pense que c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment intéressant il y avait des
drapeaux évidemment que toujours dans le
principe de décoder l'actualité il ya
des invités qui viendront notamment
laurent précisé qui va devenir bien sûr
laurent façonnent l'avenir d'ailleurs
invité régulier très certainement jean
claude mallet président la fédération il
y aura d'autres grands maîtres aussi
comme dans les anciennes émissions qu'on
avait fait
évidemment on essaie aussi de faire
participer l'ensemble du monde magique
et 1,7 cette télévision des échecs alors
on revienne sur la partie d'aujourd'hui
entre topalov et vladimir kramnik et
topalov aller avec les blancs démarrent
par le coût des quatre oui topalov qui
joue ben différemment des 4 4 mais qui
récemment a enregistré beaucoup plus de
succès avec l'avant séduction tam donc
c'est une demi surprise qu'il ait envie
de jouer des quatre îles un répertoire
très affûté très pointue et je vous les
lignes les plus compliquées dans chaque
variante normalement kramnik lui est un
adepte des défenseurs case blanche
on se rappelle que contre garry kasparov
il avait ce que le candidat mme david
avait accepté il avait mixé un peu tout
ça
bon ici très logiquement les demi-heures
kramnik ne dévie pas de sa stratégie son
répertoire d'ouvertures bien classique /
case blanche
donc on va voir un dessin classique où
est donc le seul hydrique
petite précision les ouvertures se
recase blanche ça veut dire grosso modo
qu'on va mettre les pions de 6 des 5
éventuellement ces six donc pour ce
groupe d'ouverture vous trouverez le
gambit dames la défense slave
l'asmi slave la défense nous faisons
vite chez virtuellement qui peut encore
être apparentés à des stratégies sur
cases blanches vladimir kramnik joue
rarement des extraits d ouverture sur le
gaz
mais jamais il a joué les stars viennent
quand il était petit problème il arrêté
depuis qu'il a réussi à gagner tout le
temps avec les blancs qu'avec la belle
attaque bayonetta c4 topalov dons
classiques
ça c'est le candidat normal c'est-à-dire
qu'on sacrifie le pion ici on va passer
rapidement ses six défense de force
slave calais ces trois cas les six on va
passer rapidement sur le début parce que
c'est pas le thème de l'émission et la
partie vous allez le voir et tout à fait
fantastique il faut arriver au coeur du
sujet quel développement intégral
alors là ici oui a précisé de juste on
va précéder sa rapidement mais dans
cette position eh bien il ya un autre
coup qui consiste à jouer le 3 pour
éviter la prison c'est cannes c'est hier
pour défendre avec le fou le problème 2
3 c'est que sa bouche
la sortie du four donc vesselin topalov
joue le coût principal ici qu'est
cavaliers 3 l'idée c'est que sur le coup
aussi ce qui est tout à fait possible
et bien maintenant sur le fond j'ai 5 ce
qui donne lieu à des langues extrêmement
pointus extrêmement complexe on sort le
faut d'abord jouer aux trois prêts
maintenant quand on joue cavalier f3
dans cette position ça permet plusieurs
choses notamment le coût des princes et
capri et la défense la wla grandes
variantes de la défense là réputé
extrêmement solide tout à fait alors à
quatre normales on va empêcher
évidemment un pouce et b5 que pour
protéger ses pions c'était un peu le
thème de la première partie en fait on
va récupérer le pion c4 donc on joue à
quatre qui affaiblit quelques cases
notamment la case b4 s'affaiblit cette
case là mais on s'assure de récupération
donc pourquoi
et préfère c'est affaiblissement c'est
parce que les noirs eux aussi ont fait
une concession une structure pour ces
quatre ils ont donc donné le sens
troubles ont donc chacun fait ses
petites concessions ce qui est tout à
fait logique d'ouverture faut faire des
concessions
david vivre sur l'échiquier ensemble
alors fou et funk normal pour empêcher
l'avancée de quatre contrôles très bien
15,4 classique eux trois les parties à
prendre l'option c4 en dessous
évidemment maintenant chacun complète
son développement aussi tueur fou prend
feu éclate donc la roue cloud qui est
malien profite du fait que l'option est
là pour éviter d'être chassée s'est donc
contrôler cette case qu'on me disait un
peu faible effectivement petit robe
classique en délogent les pièces qui a
validé cette dame 2 pour topalov on voit
que la la préparation de la poussie
centrale avec la dame derrière le
cavalier qui protège même si ce qu'elle
m'a dit quand même en crise c'est le
groupe principal de notre foot et 6 il a
peut-être quand même alors là déjà on
peut se poser la question si les noirs
prenez le câble et c3 après la prise ici
oui et bien le pion à 4 est en prise en
prise dans confort et les brigades
cavale et prend ou faut prendre par
exemple cavale et franck et pour
l'interview
alors ici c'est une partie qui a déjà
été joué c'est à dire c'est de la
théorie le coup c'est x 3 pour cette
position qui a été jouée par exemple ou
qu on empêche maintenant les noirs de
roquet puisse contrôler la quasi fluide
donc voilà le rock est interdit parce
que le fou contrôler la case on passe le
roi donc est dans cette position on
s'est aperçu que les compensations était
largement suffisante c'est à dire que
les blancs et un avantage assez massif
notons que qui avait pensé 3 1 apporte
pas grand chose après le coup d'oeil b2
attaque le cavalier avec le cavalier
l'option b 7 qui permet également de
mettre la dame sur la case b4 et dans
certains cas on peut au choix des cinq
exceptions j'ai cette emprise donc ici
ça ne suffit pas du tout donc on ne joue
pas ça et dans cette position et bien il
il ya des compensations énorme
maintenant les blancs vont rouvrir les
lignes et le roi noir est en difficulté
d'où l'idée donc après ou 4 kramnik ne
fait pas cette variante comprends mais
il rock voilà ça explique le coup c'est
bien le noter quand même cette petite
passe technique
alors maintenant ici par contre une fois
que le rock est évident ça devient
d'actualité de prendre donc évidemment
topalov revient et défend son pion alors
la poussée e5 aurait certainement
affaiblir les cases blanches
un don qui avait calé les dessins qui
aurait pas eu de problème pour les noirs
ouais je crois que la poussée au sein
qu'elle a déjà été joué les robinson
vous ai fait des siennes marine qui
existent aussi sa deuxième compagne ans
et donc il a préféré se garder la
mobilité des clients sans trop de poils
sa petite louane pernicieux fois g5 un
coup intéressant la menace c'est de
jouer au 6 e 5 dans cette position
maintenant que le cavaliere trois
écuries donc il peut jouer avec les
noirs ici ces procès pour bloquer le
pion aux quatre pour bloquer son
invincible cas c'est un peu le centre
des blancs échanger des pions centraux
alléger la tension c'est pour ça que les
blancs jouent à peine cinq attaquants 6
cavaliers et là on a la fameuse
configuration et loi avec les pions
diriger vers le roi ici comme sa
possibilité l'attaqué envers le roi il
faut que ce défenseur ici du roi qui est
sorti il peut y avoir des thèmes
tactique on peut penser des fois par
exemple imaginons que la dame qui bouge
mais six ont pu imaginer une fois
cavalier bouger par exemple la foux
prend et échecs et après on apprend
cavaliers échec et le fou tout de suite
est en plus de la dame le fameux fou
prend à cette fameuse voyais
effectivement ce qu'il faut voir dans la
position de départ maintenant il ya
beaucoup de flèches donc la pression est
moins lisible oui c'est sûr mais
néanmoins effectivement la base de
l'explication c'est que la structure
d'options des blancs et bien accès vers
le roi noir et que ça ça provoque des
thèmes notamment le défenseur du petit
rock c'est toujours le cavalier qui est
devant le petit rock donc lecavalier 6
il ce qu'avait dit qu'il ne peut plus
rester là puisque le tube dans le pion
blanc l'attaquent
donc il faut l'enlever et ça ça pose un
problème parce que c'est le cabinet qui
défend quoi il n'est plus là donc
maintenant la tâche ne commence alors
cavaliers des 5 alors maintenant
attention ce cavalier et emprise du
cavalier du fou topalov choisi de
prendre cali et des cinq reprises aux
prises là donc on est dans une structure
de française va rentrer davance à
l'exception peu dans la partie française
le four est enfermé ans évite les fous
de le fou noir de cases blanches restent
sous la norme allemand est enfermé ici
donc a priori ce serait plutôt
avantageux avantageux au noir bien sûr
d'avoir ces structures avec ce foot y va
s'échanger contre un coup surtout qui va
s'échanger contre le foot les planches
eva joly va revenir angers 6 très
probablement meilleur et il va le faire
dans la partie mais le foot est roi des
blancs est très très menaçant donc il va
faire l'échangé d'un de trois lits des
aiglons sort du duc loi y en a
certainement envie de recycler ce
cavalier par exemple ou un pour jouer f4
et f5 avec quand même
le bélier classique quand on a le fou
ici aussi pour protéger et pour jouer
six aussi enfin essayé de défoncer un
peu c'est le rock
exactement lorsqu'on a pas on parle pour
l'instant des perspectives des blancs
s'étaient fa moyens de temps et a fait
alors mais il faut voir que les noirs ne
sont pas du tout exemple contre jeu
puisqu'ils à la colonne c'est qui est
ouverte par exemple alors cette fameuse
colonne la colonne s'est donc on peut
remettre voilà on va y mettre une tour
les pions les pions blancs qui sont un
peu affaibli maintenant les deux ans à 4
et b2 nécessite des pièces à la défense
parce que la dame noire est certainement
passé soit 500 b6 l'option des 4 est
également faible
donc tout ça fait que les noirs ont du
jeu donc maintenant c'est une course de
côté gauche de l'échiquier local elle
dame c'est les noirs qui ont davantage
notamment parce que ce options et en a
quatre et un ans à 2 ça veut dire ça
provoque urines d'un coup de faiblesse
et leur côté droit sur les droits et
bien c'est des blancs qui ont l'avantagé
toujours parce que il ya ce option
qu'elle a et il ya ce plan stéphane qui
arrive qui est l'avant séduction f donc
c'est une lutte est une course on est
dans une course de vitesse
le premier arrivé va gagner tu as fait
donc là cramique choisi de revenir en g6
et finalement d'essayer de s'échanger
contre ce fou qui est trop menaçant ne
veut pas donner contre les cavaliers
avec un four à quai sur son roi ça le
gêne et je pense qu'il a raison alors
qu'il peut faire échanger a tenté
d'échanger souffre ou carrées g5 de tout
pas loin oui comme tu disais stéphane y
avait le choix il fallait faut avancer
turenne donc faut bouger le cavalier tu
avais mentionné la case eu un tout à
l'heure mais évidemment c'était pas
exprès topalov topalov cg100 voilà le
problème et nancy les noirs choississant
soit rejetée sur une combinaison
immédiate s'était fait durer cavaliers
pros pion aux six comprendre réussi
voilà campera variante qu'on peut
montrer fois montré d'ailleurs imaginant
h6 pour attaquer le cavalier seul a tout
simplement car il y prendre 6 surprenant
attaque la dame la tour donc il faudra
prendre il faut reprendre
on prend un point gagnant au passage et
en même temps on appuie toutes les cases
blanches parce que maintenant le fonds
va revenir en batterie avec la dame
elle en fait grave toutes les cases
blanches ont été prises non les à toute
la classe b 5
voilà donc calé j'ai cinq ici tour 8,2
kramnik tour vite c'est un coût qui
prétendent avancé des pions f
oui est également qu'il y ait fait que
les andes et de calais fidh qui contrôle
très bien leurs accessoires très bon
défenseur le qualifie donc c'était aussi
les plus on réussisse il faut leur
mettre effectivement vite pour défendre
la cage s'est t il à cacher 6 et en plus
c'est un coût qui peut être
éventuellement peut préparer le schisme
maintenant on doit rester cotée topalov
ses attaquants marionnettes classique ou
f4 abete au paddock c'est un joueur
direct
belga une position il est indispensable
de jouer direct c'est à dire qu'il peut
pas se contenter de perdre autant parce
que dans trois couples a dit mercredi
qu'il a trouvé du contrôle donc qui
échangent de fou évidemment puisqu'il
peut pas permettre à vaincre annick f5
avec son frangin 6
c'est ce l'obligerait de de prendre et
de cassis sa structure de turin il faut
noter au passage stéphane une petite
variante qu'on n'a pas mentionné mais
c'est que à la place de f4 si topaloff
avait joué fou profond ça c'est quand
même important pour un fou voilà fou
profond et bien sinon justement on
prendrait des informations du point fr
qu'elle a reprise standard dans ce genre
de situations avec l'idée qu'on a ouvert
la colonne ans qu'on va mettre la tour
on va ramener à tous ici voilà on va
mettre la dame aux recettes la torah
fuite qui va revenir sur la tf 5 et
c'est comme ça qu'on veut ce genre de
position ok donc alors f4 donc fou prend
d'emprunt logique et la f5 de kramnik il
veut empêcher lui-même l'a poussé m 5
donc ça paraisse apparaissait un coût
jugé nécessaire une méthode radicale
pour empêcher d'avancer 25 sur la prise
en passant qui aurait pu être très très
forte
alors on va montrer la présente
assemblée n'a pas souvent on va la
montre et hop prison m6 avec le service
on ajoute deux cases le pion on a le
droit de considérer au coup d'après
unique ont appris que le pion à bouger
que d'une case en cas de prise de clans
c'est la prise en passant le touriste à
riespach et cavaliers prendre dans qui
défend le matin reichstett qui font
l'âme interagissaient et donc on se
retrouve dans une position où topalov un
petit peu de difficulté avec son fou
c'est un pas ce fouillis fermé par
ticket aux voix là et peut-être que a
pris 1,6 par exemple si le calibre
peuvent sauter ou si c'est exactement ça
et on se retrouve avec un problème de
mauvais fond de cette fois un mauvais
fouet que le fou de le fou de topalov
serait très faible comparé aux fauves la
dina camion pourquoi il faut pas la
prison passant à parler avantageuse et
c'est pourquoi tout palau choisi le coût
de développement châssis foudroie enfin
plus standard je dirais plutôt classique
tout est roi il faut il faut donner de
l'air à ses deux tours pour l'instant
qu'il joue pas peut-être là il veut la
faire jouer peut-être qu'il veut essayer
de passer ce tour pour l'attack aussi de
ce côté là et dans ce cas l'or après
ramener la deuxième tour ici
oui c'est toujours bon de lire les tours
éventuellement à signaler que topalov de
se mettre à jouer de l'autre côté il
peut aussi envisager de temps en temps
de d'occuper la colonne c'est henri
venir soit cette colonne voilà je
voulais jouer dan b5 aussi au passage
avec ce côté là voilà donc pour
l'instant il garde toute la souplesse de
sa position topalov il a un avantage des
espaces qui compense le fait qu'ils sont
fous seraient sur la même couleur que
ses pions car la fuite
carrier fuite
granic qui protège ses solides ses
souliers protège aussi les rocistes lire
aussi que son cavalier qui était de
toute façon pas très bien placé un décès
qui faisaient rien il était complètement
dominé par les qui ont mont-blanc et
puisque toutes les quatre été prise on
ne voyait pas trop de route intéressante
pour le cavalier ya pas de case qui soit
intéressant d'ailleurs en attente et il
défend un peu loin il est bien alors il
a recyclé sa pièce une meilleure case la
case où on voudrait mettre le cavalier
fuite éventuellement c'est enfin le
cavalier noir ça serait la case aux 4
mais malheureusement cette case celle là
hors de portée - que dans les chemins
qui mènent tous les chemins toutes les
cases sont minés par l'ingénieur par les
pions ici impossible de mettre calé sur
cette casse toi n'y a pas d'autres cale
sur l'échiquier qui soit extrêmement
prometteuse donc ici très logiquement
kramnik mais son cavalier à la défense
du roi est là parce qu'ils anticipent
même que topalov de l'avenir la tête et
à taux plein nous sort un implant
toujours d'attac à la taupe à l'offre en
achat alors l'idée
toujours d'attaqué toujours la dalle
l'idée droit chemin évidemment c'est de
pouvoir peut-être mètres des tours
derrière et je vous dis 4 casser la
structure de pian et on fait ouvrir les
colonnes sur le rang donc ça c'est
classique
non c'est un petit coup un côté qui paye
pas de mine si souvent quand on a joué
le pion au fc peut être utile de mettre
le roi sûrs achetant sait jamais s'il ya
des échanges pour y avoir des échecs un
jour ou l'autre
voilà mais c'est certainement là c'est
très bien réparé il n'a pas retouché un
sourire ou un chien n'est pas du tout un
coup de défense du roi ou d'anticipation
quoi que ce soit c'est un coup pour
préparer le tour j'ai l'impression de la
colo jeff taffe c'est un peu de
libération de gaz
à noter que le coup après le coup j'ai
quatre des pions vont s'échanger c'est à
dire que tu rêves 5 va disparaître et
son gilet blanc va disparaître donc on
peut se dire c'est dangereux pour
topalov parce que si lecavalier fuite
arrivé sur cette case l5 me serais bien
eh bien oui ça serait une situation de
blocage
comment y arriver mais ça va y arriver
donc c'est ça en fait la pointe c'est
que pendant ce temps vous pouvez vous
permettre avec les blanches g4 dans ce
genre de position uniquement parce que
vous avez tout bien calculé que
précisément tactiquement le cavalier
noir n'arrivera pas sur cette case à 5
de blocage
ce qui veut dire que quand on va juger
quatre après les changes des pions gfc
bien on va avoir la menace f 4l 5 qui va
donc dans le sens tout à fait donc c'est
du stratégiquement c'est faux si la case
exsangue peut être bloquée on va voir
que topalov à bien tous vu et c'est pas
le cas tours s'est vite travnik fidèle à
ses principes développe dans la pièce
qui jouait pas et maintenant ça y est
elle est en jeu
éventuellement pour revenir sur la casse
et c'est aussi pour défendre en cas
d'attaqué défense
en tout cas
beaucoup plus utile d'avoir une pièce
dans le jeu qu'une pièce à l'extérieur
qui aurait été oublié et là ça y est ils
envoient tout de suite topalov qui joue
pas tout rejet en avant il envoie gk
tout de suite et tout utile menaces puis
on prend qui ont envie d'apprendre cette
langue est une pure honnêtement avec
deux pions ensuite très très fort avec
une attaque est derrière qui sort et qui
seraient trop fort donc il faut
évidemment défendre kramnik choisi le
ku'damm 17 protège en transparence ici
donc si tu en prends tu comprends et la
dame ici protège parfaitement le pur
fcmq notons au passage stephen que après
la double prise pions problème 5 1 et
est une possibilité et puis on prend on
peut se dire qu'on a créé un pion passé
oui ce qui est vrai puisqu'il a plus
d'opposition
malheureusement on ne peut pas l'avancer
tout de suite parce que lecavalier fuite
contrôle donc on perdrait du matériel et
locaux d'al au prochain coup c'est soit
qu'ils avaient aussi soit h6 d'abord
pour chasser le cavalier qui on se
retrouve avec un cavalier bloqueurs ont
imaginé un cahier noir sur cette case
il attaque les pions des 4 et f garder
il peut pas être attaquée il doit pas
être attaqué donc ici faisait en fait il
est protégé derrière le pion blanc on a
créé un pion passé mais en fait un
passage j'ai tout donné une case où il y
avait des platines indique ce qui serait
très très grave c'est donc passé le nom
d'utilisateur donc sur thème décède et
bien un peu pâlotte choisi de jouer
toujours jihad toujours qu'un mode
attaque tour j'ai investi un total of
qui décidément ne mollira pas lady
l'idée évidemment c'est qu'après
maintenant la prise bombay que les
blancs peuvent faire quand ils veulent
et tout de suite ça libère l'action de
la tour sur loing ça peut être très fort
donc là et il peut ensuite envisager
aussi de doubler les tours un tour un g3
et
la deuxième nous aussi c'est le plan tel
plan fawcett kramnik ramène sont fous
sont fous qui jouait plus ici il faut
bien le retrouver des classes donc on va
qui quand même serré l'un des sérieux là
choquant c'est à dire que fawcett menace
d'alléger la tension ils veulent
franchir pour les snacks il veut changer
ce cavalier trop menaçants c'est
pourquoi toi pas là d'ailleurs l'enlève
tout de suite car hier 3 pas d'échangé
avec topalov tour ses cadres alors la
trace et qu'elle joue un coup pour ces
quatre sans doute alors déjà il fait bon
un tout petit peu près cent des cas mais
c'est tellement protégés pour l'instant
le sujet et pas des cap des 400 qu'il
est protégé sur à casser ça et aussi sur
des quatre cases faible qui n'est pas
attaquable et il peut faire pression sur
le pion ici v2 cette case est aussi
protégé par le fou donc pressions en
tout cas tout de suite sur le plan cadre
alors là c'est très intéressant de voir
le coût de topalov calme et vraiment
symptomatique de son style absolument
inimitable il décide de jouer tout rejet
de donc en donnant plus on a quatre
puisque maintenant que tu vas 4 n'est
plus défendu voilà la prise via la dame
qui est derrière est prise ça fait deux
contre un donc ici il choisit de cette
affirmation puisque on va voir dans la
partie il y a eu au préalable défense du
pur f5 c'était direction projet quatre
tours prend et maintenant que le pion
avec 5 n'est plus en prise tout recours
à quatre
donc ça c'est la partie on va y revenir
après mais surtout dans cette position
après ton g2 enfin après tour ses cadres
il aurait pu jouer le coup b3 qui se
serait privé de jouer un coup comme b3
dans cette position en cas d'atteinte
ça fait quand même plaisir de jeu b3 on
défend nos pions à quatre voies
latérales tartas tour du temps on défend
donc ça c'est vrai que ça fait plaisir à
jouer mais maintenant topaloff avait
plus loin il veut pas laisser g litre
entrée sur lequel ses trois dauphines
ont anticipé la tour va revenir en cette
histoire c'est celle qui aurait doublé
at war et ensuite vladimir kramnik va
ramener sa deuxième tour ans s'est vite
et revenir une fois de plus avec la tour
sur lesquels sur la terrasse de la casse
faible et là ça viendra prix grimpent
alors toutes les pièces d'autos pas
l'offre et à toutes les pièces qui sont
donc en fait il d'un city laïcité
topalov à jouer
il incitait topalov hb3 topaloff il a
dit rien à [ __ ] documents a4 c'est pas
grave c'est pas mon problème 17 ans il a
pensé il la pensée alors donc il faut
changer quatre la tour prend g4 logique
et maintenant tout reprend 4 ça il a
donné le pion au no comprend pourquoi on
a d'abord échange d'espions puisque là
sinon les blancs auraient pris ici et
après prise de la dame
on aurait mangé le pion aux 5 c'est ça
on aurait fait les change donc ça
explique pourquoi les noirs ont pris
d'abord et maintenant évidemment tout
balough il n'est pas fou il dit bon mais
cette tour pour moi elle est hors jeu
parce que le jeu si vers le coin
donc plutôt que d'échanger matour hop je
ramène la tour du côté où ça va faire
mal et c'est au tout de suite se
trouvant jouer mais loin elle joue plus
allez allez allez allez en défense du
mauvais côté faut noter au passage que
l'animateur n'était gagné un pion
mondial gagné un tueur en série
mais ça fait peur quand même on va dire
que là il ya quand même déjà tout de
suite la menace assez directe frangy cet
échec
ensuite il y avait cinq comme bélier
possible donc les devants tous et tous
ses arguments il ya plus de choix il
faut jouer le fou devenir chronique
cégétiste puisque c'est la seule défense
raisonnable pour ce plongeon des phares
en changer six on est protégé par le
cavalier par le pion et là tout de suite
topalov joue le coup je dirais classique
dans cette position j'irai en blitz ont
affiché n'y a pas de seconde 1 pour
jouer ce genre de coup c'est logique on
amène un bélier de plus pour essayer de
casser cette position et le meilleur
bélier l'imposition sélection puisque
les pions ça coûte pas cher celle que
les fantassins qu'on envoie aux
massacres
oui ch4 voilà ce suite à ce cadre l idh
5 évidemment pour casser le plonger 6
échanger et à peut-être à prix sacrifiés
la dame se peut
ça va pas très loin et là on a chaud
pour kramnik bell aliant cette situation
je pense que vladimir kramnik ne doit
pas être rien ne devait pas être devait
pas être à l'aise ne devait pas être à
l'aise du tout mais j'ai commencé à
sentir que ça d'être assez dur et la
chronique il au micro qui craque pas
tout de suite il joue un coût
relativement calme être ya trois
beaucoup de possibilités aussi il faut
voir que la caisse noire se gênent 1
c'est très difficile de défendre plus
que ce qui est possible là bas ce genre
de position c'est très très dur à jouer
pour les non parce que c'est très loin
d'avoir fait un tueur passé il faut qu'
il faut que les noirs jouent sur essayé
de tenir ici de ce côté-là et joue sur
le long terme sur cet avantage de pions
ici de créer un pion passé pour faire
diversion
la première pour la première
problématique stéphane dans cette
situation c'est de se défendre contre
les menaces qui arrive c'est à dire h5
son projet si c'est au projet si ce
sacrifice qui est très direct on va là
tout de suite tombé 4 donc s'il oublie
toujours directe aux palois c'est
maintenant la menace est simple c'est
tout âge prend et sur une bo pris soin
du pion soit du cavalier ces sacrifices
à ces sacrifices suivi d'un franc et
matt sacrifices et ceux où il a signé
face ils peuvent oui c'est ça c'est pas
vraiment sacrifice puisque c'est un bas
de forcer un accord c'est effectivement
ces sacrifices qu'on a envie de jouer
d'où le coup de krabi qui suit dam des
cinq premiers chantiers français général
à des changes
j'essaie les championnats puisque cette
dame si celle-là qui parle c'est celle
là qui menace de devenir angers 6 donc
il faut essayer de les changer au plus
tôt donc ici naturellement sur pied un
projet si son joug d'un programme alors
imaginons une surprise imaginons pu
engranger six dames trois là évidemment
on prendrait adam qui ont franchi cet
échec qui empruntent cet échec et bien
tout simplement on va apprendre et
comprendre avec l'or noir n'y a pas de
tour h4 maths parce que le fawcett
contrôle voilà ici il n'ya pas de
matches ici puisqu'elle le fou qui
contrôlent la quasi normal puisque la
tour aura empêché le droit de sortir ici
il ya tout simplement rien après des
échecs pour
voici 6 peut-être pas mais si roissy ce
que sur f5 échec et la m5 échec avec le
fou mais one et le faux est en fait
simplement un point voilà il n'y a pas
de mater la dame pour à sacrifier contre
une des tours mais lorsque ce qu'il faut
noter c'est quand même que visuellement
on a eu l'impression d' attaques
spectaculaires alors que les bleus ont
donné une dame pour rien c'est dire le
potentiel data qu'il y ait dans la
position de décines topalov ici tout à
fait donc les charges de down kramnik
vient à propos et c'est pourquoi
d'ailleurs topalov le recuit et dames
ses douze loups surprenant dams et deux
parce que la dame n'est plus apte à clim
et mais on se demande mais ont très bien
effectivement la dame gardes contrôlent
ici la menace reste patente
on a évité les changer d'âme mais le
pion gaydoul est en prise et derrière la
dame va être attaqué hélas elle n'aura
plus de cases pour rester sur la colonne
plus exactement tout sera pris et
d'ailleurs c'est ce que fait cramer tour
prend b2 alors qu abu topalov palestine
topalov a tout vu justement puisque ici
maintenant c'est l'heure de après tombé
de me les donne la dame maintenant ça
marche donc là sacrifice moi qui on
prend avec sacrifice et la différence
avait tout à l'heure c'est évidemment
que quand la tour prend au c2 pour la
tour prendre la tour par là maintenant
tout de faire la variante on veut voir
le foot pro ne sera plus aux prédictions
sont les 7,3 prendre rapproche cette
tour j'ai cet échec touché cet échec au
roi justice donc c'est le roi benoît
suite suivra ensuite les échecs voilà le
roi au monde
on amènera la deuxième tour voilà 7 avec
les musiciens revient la même chose de
jouer directement aux injustices et la
f5 s'allier échec
hélas la dame n'est plus ici voilà donc
condamnatoire elle peut pas prendre le
fou donc c'est la différence en a donné
la dame mais le fou maintenant fait un
vrai échec donc ici le méchec plein le
seul coup un échec plein le seul coup
dans 7 pays afin de relier deux coups
mais les deux sont des zones rouges et 5
fu gsm et ici on joue simplement tôt
plongé 50 ans quand les cinq avec des
menaces des chèques double
le bilan matériel c'est qu'il ya un fou
pour une dame aux menaces des mâles et
les douars n'ont aucune menace
et puis le roi noir et matois tout
simplement menace des maths par exemple
ou avec échec avec le four même si la
dame prenait fou après imaginons qu'elle
n'avait bougé et or et mat
ici sur la colonne maintenance et vous
pouvez vérifier tranquillement la mafia
un match forcément yama de forcer et le
deuxième coup au deuxième poteau rush 5
et dans ce cas là sans trop d'espoir la
f6 je crois qu'il doit guinée tout de
suite et c'est peut-être dans ce cas là
il ya un mois qu'il escomptait 5 et 6
voilà on intercepte le fou c'est que les
pièces les plus importantes de défense
est la dernière pièce de défense aux
menaces de jouer tour g5 suivi d'un math
en quelques coups c'était un tour un g5
rouages si ce geste il est noir joue une
coupe comme dame de deux là ont pour
fait tour un g5 placer ma tante trois
échecs en voire d'orage s'il faut parler
sur la cage de 4 à cause du cavalier
donc il faut venir acheter la tour 5 g
six doubles échecs dont je 3% je sais ça
fait c'est aussi un saut de chaîne c'est
un peu plus rassurant c'est l'échec
était entouré d'autres fois il faut
jouer le rail belge croit qu'en cas
double échec quand il faut bouger leur
art et la simple là il aurait donc c'est
une attaque énorme avec sacrifice nos
dames et donc tout ceci juste assez
chaud tout ceci c'est très très chaud et
donc on ne peut répondre la dame sinon
on est mat on ne peut pas pour la dame
donc il faut que kramnik trouve autre
chose et donc il joue à 5
oui elle 5 ce qui est pas mal alors
classique ouais ça c'est tout à fait
c'est le gros c'est classique c'est à
dire qu'en jouant h5 on empêche
l'ouverture de cette colonne on va dire
que là le pion ne peut plus
est repris on n'ose plus prendre il peut
plus être pris il peut plus prendre
surtout les blondes peuvent pas jouer
pour compter six comme ça bouge c'est
souvent voilà il se sert du plan comme
bouclier c'est classique ce genre de
coup de pouce et les exactement de
procéder mais les skins topaloff
il est là il a trouvé une autre idée
pour sa colonne il n'a pas peur j7 g7
france est énorme le deuxième set est
fils de dom consécutive n'y a plus que
ça au final puisque la dame est attaqué
la tour est attaqué alors là c'est assez
colossal alors il faut voir stéphane une
première remarque très simple c'est que
la dame n'est pas ne peut pas être
prises
donc ça c'est important sur le coup tout
repenser 2 ça va très vite c'est un
attend 3 6 1 matin trois comptes
notamment avec des doubles échecs ou
l'échec pourrait même qu'il faut prendre
du roi prend obligatoire c'est le seul
tour g8 échec
le roi n'a qu'une case il faut revenir
et tour un g7
matt nat puisque le roi n'a plus de
katrina peu de cases donc
première remarque quand on revient dans
cette position c'est que la dame n'est
pas une option en l'absence d'option
tranquillité d'âme qui fait maths en
trois dans chronique a choisi de prendre
j'ai quatre à six parce qu'il a choisi
c'est à g et n'a plus le choix
chronique n'a plus le choix l'autre coup
pour éviter l'ouverture de la colonne
s'est par exemple cavaliers h tête qui
est une option possible
là je me demande
comment conclure ça eh bien je crois que
d'hommes g6 doit faire parfaitement le
faire attac l'option aussi se menacent
m'attendre un coup donc qui est
imparable en tous sens très difficile
appareils food et 8 imaginant food et 8
fou des mythes à protège le pion ruciste
par la tour et dans ce cas là tout
simplement
alors ici bon c'est pas si simple il
faut encore recompiler mais on peut par
exemple prendre le pion à 5 face à lyon
hcl va y avoir que je regarde qui
égalité matérielle s'arrête dans la
norme
en fait c'est tout simple qui égalité
matérielle l'a menacé d'un projet tête
oui dame prend elle a certainement
fonctionne et ce qui ne fonctionne pas
mais maintenant je parle qui pourrait
bientôt arriver ou hi5
peu importe ici dans cette position les
biens immatériels avec une attaque
énorme le un pion g7 qui menacent de
faire dame à tout moment quand on l'a
dernier dernière petite astuce
importante c'est que la dame noire ne
peut pas venir à eux deux pour essayer
de faire des choses parce que la tourbe
il n'est pas défendu ouais donc que
absence totale de contre jeu pour les
noirs ici il faut prendre donc après
voilà ici
vladimir kramnik n'a plus le choix il
objet de prendre les 3 il faut prendre
maintenant voilà qu'après muc ne faut
pas que pas le seul travail puisque la
et bientôt apple choisit de prendre la
fuite et de fer d'un même temps donc
damme et chuck en grand échec au roi
dont trois reprises possible trois ans
plus possible et y a pas le choix il n'y
a pas le choix elles sont récents elles
sont presque tous perdants elles sont
presque toutes perdante sauf une il n'ya
alors il n'y avait qu'une seule option
pour vladimir kramnik ici et est la
surprise générale est bien là où je
crois qu'on assiste à une des plus
grosses gaffes qu'on ait vu dans
l'histoire des championnats du monde
d'échecs avec des plus grosses derrière
et c'est vrai moyen n'a eu quelques-unes
1 c'est pas là fischer avait donné un
fond plat fromage contreuse pasquine en
72 il y avait donné un fou oui de faire
le fou proche de moi là exactement vers
un pion c'était une gaffe
oui on savait pas ce qui est une garce
ou s'il avait calculé son coup il avait
notre calcul et d'analysé c'est un truc
vraiment spectaculaire on va vous
montrer ce que je voulais dire qu'andy
alors on va montrer qu est ce qu a joué
kramnik il a joué x 8
il aurait un coup franc et fuites tout
simplement c'est bien c'est matt ses
lattes seimat forcé matt puisqu'après
tout reprend g4 qui n'a pas été jouée
par total et on va voir si incroyable
mais c'est ça qu'on va voir après deux
tours pranger quatre fous g7
et bien tout simplement le ku'damm c7
est bien c max et il y avait plus rien
plus que le procès pourrait pêcher le
mat le conte prochainement
c'est d'amener son échec royaume peut
encore faire des échecs à 9,1 oui enfin
un échec aucune nation mais il ya
cavaliers g1 intercepte les chèques et
pauillac asab 3 et on peut plus faire
des chèques ici puisqu'elle cavaliers on
peut pas faire des chèques qui s'y passe
ya le cavalier et cette tour est
complètement inefficace
nicolas cazier et la cage et deux
contrôlés par la tour donc on peut il ya
plus rien pour les noirs et le match ici
est imparable
incroyable tout simplement il faut
donner la dame
donc on peut revoir stéphane depuis le
début parce qu'il faudrait donner la
dame en fait parce que c'est vraiment
trop spectaculaire ce qui s'est passé ça
a été trop vite en fait on va le revoir
ça donc en fait c'est matt
c'est la surprise ce match est un
plateau par l'ofs arrive à une position
où il a monté une attaque fantastique
très bien monté et c'est également une
grosse pression à venir quand on y croit
sans ménagement granik a pas trouvé la
défense qui allait bien et la licra
crâne et craque en fuite
au lieu de commander un peu tard roy
prend la fuite on peut l'on peut le
montrer que roy a pris fuite aurait pu
tenir la position
tout simplement il ya encore évidemment
une attaque c'est pas c'est pas c'est
pas fini il reste
évidemment on va prendre ce pion au togo
car les versions de se passer avec des
mèches et si ce danger si ce
paramètre-là d'aval attaque
déjà on a le perpétuel possibles causes
de cet échec le prêt quand on veut donc
oui si c'est une position très difficile
pour les noirs assez difficile en tout
cas il faut jouer dans me2 très
certainement des deux attaques et des
menaces adam 30 cavaliers avec l'échec
donc là je crois qu'il ya beaucoup
d'émissions notamment en coup droit là
nul au moins avec les blancs déjà donc
amené en tout cas la partie continue les
bons sont mieux dans son élan son mieux
mais la partie continue il ya ya ya
attaque il ya toujours attaque mais
c'était encore tenable et la dernière
reprise possible était pour prendre
notons qu'on sait maintenant la c1 match
et là c'est la terre qui était un match
basique avec dame échec
ça va être avec des métaux alors je suis
comme des magiciens damage 5 g 7 est
maintenant tour en voilà et c'est matt
cm tous ses matches au coup d'après
après il faut gsm qui surprend et ses
matches voilà donc tout simplement et
donc francs et fuite père est là donc
donc on se dit déjà c'est une partie
linéaire un jouet de bien jouer et au
challenge fantastique chronique à
patrice corriveau 31e coup il ya
peut-être une préparation c'était
peut-être une préparation topalov à la
maison c'est possible pourquoi pas il a
dû jouer beaucoup de parties
d'entraînement sur ce thème c'est
certain il est familiarisé ce genre de
pression et puis c'est un super jour
d'attac surtout et là surprise surprise
ils comptent pas leur projet kde il
préfère il a maintenant ils pensaient
plus au matériel parce que saddam est
attaqué alors plutôt que de prendre avec
la tour et enlever ce pion et les niches
trompe et il joue le coup suivant
d'alger six échecs au revoir alors ça
paraît bon seulement il ya une petite
subtilité qui va faire la différence
après fou g7 tout simplement donc ici
bon ici de clients déclarent ya plus il
ya plus cette possibilité de maths qui
avait tout à l'heure avec la dame
entendu lui non plus n'a plus rien à
voir néanmoins la position des blanches
et où la pression blanche est toujours
toujours que la belle a fait on a encore
une attaque énorme donc veselin topalov
travail rata matin hirata matuidi et
rappelé m oui c'est inexplicable
topalov ratatat donc là on va quand même
voir cette conférence de presse mais
qu'on n'a pas évidemment tout de suite
puis débroussailler mais on verra ça
lors de la quatrième partie troisième
lors de la troisième partie et l'a donc
là topalov commun continue son attaque
évidemment il peut il veut quand même
continuer à essayer de gagner cette
partie au moins de la sauver et joseph
fiennes très joli coup f5 puisque là
c'est un bélier il va menacer 120 tf6 et
japon pour menacer mate aussi il
appartient évidemment de la prise du
cavalier puisqu'avec to ride améliorer
matin oui autre remarque également
stéphane qui est importante donc tu
comprends cavaliers ne marche pas f5 on
continue à accroître notre notre
pression d'un sf6 assure la dame noire
ne peut pas vraiment entré sur la zone
parce qu'ils auraient même d'être
entouré vite et chaque échec tout à fait
donc ici
pour l'instant c'est pour ça qu'il a
joué probablement assez rapidement
d'alger six échecs pour jouer f5 parce
qu'il s'est dit dans cette position
c'est pas possible qu'ils s'en sortent
menace m6 et adam peut pas bouger il
peut pas prendre mon cavalier donc ici
il pensait sans doute l gagnant quand
même noter ce qui ne peut pas la gagner
tout à fait tout à fait mais l'ancrage
nick c'est quand même un très grand
défenseur et il va il va trouver les
bons coups alors ils tours 7
inquiet pas capables qui n'est pas
forcément le meilleur coût est
d'ailleurs en plus déjà en plus tard une
gaffe vient jamais tout seul
oui les jouets l'ipad ont leurs pas dans
leur assiette très probablement parce
qu'il ya un problème mais la partie est
très très compliqué ça paraît compliqué
mais c'est quand même des très très très
bon joueur tout à fait tord set et l'a
donc mes talents cf6 donc attaque à tour
et le fond donc ça y est on va récupérer
du matos
côté blanc donc maintenant évidemment
comme la truite n'est plus en prise et
bien fait logiquement ya plus d'un an
prend 1,8 donc maintenant dames 2
toujours avec l'idée d'un prend cavalli
avec échec il ya aussi une possibilité
de maths si lecavalier m par exemple
angers 5 et avec la tour ici ça fait
comme une belle bathory face au roi
blanc c'est toujours désagréable donc
contre attaque de kramnik essaie de
sauver les meubles en bois qui subit
toujours parce que le matériel ya juste
une qualité de plus pour vladimir
kramnik ce qui est très peu quand on
voit un pion v6 et toutes les pièces
mais c'est donc ici d'un projet casa
évidemment je dirais l'armement dga 3 on
défend cavaliers maintenant dans l'ituri
dame donc donc on peut menacer les
choses hélas taux étant prises aussi ça
fait beaucoup
donc la cramif choisi tôt à 100
évidemment il va pas surtout rupture du
mat évidemment donc là il continue à
garder un oeil sur son fou et si les
blancs prennent du pillon et bien et
vient kramis peut prendre le carrier
puisque la tour protège
voilà avec échec qu'il faut pas prendre
évidemment le fou est donc temps pas là
je trouve autre chose il joue tour c1
et là c'est une deuxième erreur de
topalov oui et pourtant qu'à l'ère un
bon coup puisque tour c'est un va
menacer ici un échec à l'air mortels
c'est une erreur de topalov
effectivement parce qu'il y avait un
coup très fort un coup très très
puissant ici c'était le coup de damages
5 alors intéressant ce coût de la
machine parce qu'on se demande vraiment
ce qu'ils savent ce que ça change
pourquoi donc la première remarque c'est
après dun prendre trois on joue cavani
geste complètement inattendu qui est
chez 5 des fonds la case au cap
défendez tf3 donc pas là il n'y a pas
d'atteinte n'y a pas d'échec et les
menaces ici sont complètement imparable
donc la menace et d'un pro tour échec
mais d'un projet cette note
et c'est un paradis a pas de défense
donc ici d'un match 5 à défendre vos
droits
c'est une première chose mais nouveau
nas rien c'est ça qui est rigolo c'est
qu'on menace pas de rupture quand j'ai
cette passion et dan franck et relief
trois échecs
donc ça menace passe à côté noir ont
leur disposition un coup c'est à vous de
jouer
ils peuvent choisir un coup
pour ces deux par exemple personne ou
1,5 et maintenant toujours un coup
spectaculaire tour g3 un coup tranquille
un coup tranquille défend le cavalier f3
et menacent donc tu reprends g7 cette
fois ci parce qu'il est plus d'un point
f3 échéant prince serait mortel puisque
cela menacerait damas schmid analyste
après l'option c'est surtout ça ici très
importante ongi 3 à noter que le coutour
j'ai un échec n'apporte tourbe est un
échec napeo forster rien que je fous
j'ai interpellé une pièce en une pièce
est au fond c'est sécurisant ouattara
veut reprendre la taille sera blanc est
extrêmement bien défendu malgré deux
pièces noires sur la deuxième il ya
rennes qui passe en fait y en a qui
passent principalement grâce à ces deux
pièces qui moisit attaquer défendre et
attaquer tout à fait tout à fait et donc
ici il semblerait d'après le ku'damm h5
donc menaces rien menaces tour g3
défendre qu'il y ait 3 suivi de gens
proches de cette saignée pas de défense
pour les noirs on n'a pas trouvé donc on
n'a pas trouvé alors tour c1 quand même
à l'air un très bon goût mais mais mais
en fait tout simplement crâne y voit la
bouche tout simplement bouche ça y est
et en fait sa tour qui était un peu hors
jeu elle a du jeu puisqu'elle va
s'échanger contre une pièce active et ça
ça change tout parce que cette tour
était quand même beaucoup plus active en
juin
donc voilà voilà l'erreur qu'a fait
notre amie eva topalov winehouse est
inexplicable toujours aussi dynamique
est aussi actif que topalov allait
changer une pièce date est comme ça
contre la tourbe et de l'année vers
kramix est pas un c'est pas le genre de
des changes qu'il aime bien faire
normalement et ils échangent et la
chronique et ne prend pas la tour tout
de suite mais il veut gagner du temps
donc il fait d'abord un échec
oui pour prendre et warrick échec alors
on peut pas défendre avec le cavalier
puisque la dame sur les emprises on
aurait pu défendre avec le fou mais le
four était dans une position très
passive c'est vrai qu'il peut peut-être
mettre son futur jet set pour prendre
le poète perse et donc il reste qu'une
solution c3g 2 mais dans ce cas là on
prend avec échec avec déchets donc on
gagne du temps moi je ne parle pas
oui on signale un petit problème de
micro apparemment voilà donc c'est ça a
été réglé oui parce que proche des 3 ici
c'est parce que l'eau coule le coût
normal mais maintenant il ya beaucoup
d'opportunités pour les divers chronique
bonnes chances de défense il faut noter
par exemple que comprend g7 n'est plus
possible à cause de tout reproche de
s'être enfin c'est possible mais on va
arriver dans une situation où il ya tour
et deux pions contre deux pièces mineurs
et le roi blanc risque d'être aussi
faible que le roi noir dans une
opposition à noter au passage que toutes
les finales maintenant sont très
difficiles pour les blancs parce qu'au
final est bien ce qui va jouer c'est
plus les chances d'attac
mais c'est des pions a et dépasser dames
4 alors les dents kramnik et s'est
échoué en décharge et 7 cette dame
la pression reste tendue topalov et
enfin évite évite les changes avec fouet
4 donc là topalov menaces qui avaient
des g5 celui de cavani pour entourer
cette cabane chez 5 pour prendre la tour
ici et puis le pion aux 6 ou 6 mai ça
élimine deux défenseurs du foot et ça
c'est très fort donc toujours grosse
initiatives pour topalov mais si ça sera
encore proposition en échange d'armes et
la même pas là aussi je dirais même plus
une proposition stéphane c'est presque
un échange de dette forcé ouais parce
qu'il ya le seul coup c'est d'am-dam
h4rem h cup mais ça pose un problème
c'est que le fou pour être bougés
certainement maintenant je trouve la
mach 4 on pourra jouer maintenant le fou
à lier est plus dure et plus le clouage
et donc on se retrouve avec une qualif
plus la tour ensuite va s'activer c'est
très certainement des élections a et b
et c qui ont la cote il faut mater comme
ses pions là vont être énormes donc la
problématique de topalov maintenant
qu'il a raté beaucoup de chances d'accès
de ces débats il faut qu'ils continuent
sont d'attaqué qu'il essaie d'aller
mater donc il prend date au balo francs
comprend et maintenant fou gsm tout
simplement donc là je pense que
l'anthropologue son plan c'est de jouer
maintenant au f4 reprend et ensuite avec
ses deux pions de créer des menaces mais
déjà déjà les mouches ont changé d'âne
oui déjà à partir de ce moment
parce que ses deux pions là qu'on a
oublié depuis tout à l'heure maintenant
eh bien ils vont créer et contre menace
et ça va être difficile il ya plus
d'hommes sur l'échiquier donc les
chances d'atteindre sont amoindries
c'est certain donc ici vladimir kramnik
maintenant on va commencer à pousser ses
pions et voilà il fait tout de suite
d'ailleurs donc il faut il faut
évidemment qu'ils créent maintenant
c'est contre kaunas parce que ça reste
très dangereux tout ça notons au passage
puisque c'est important de le signaler
le fouet fuite étant prises le fou g7 et
on prie donc on aurait pu déplacer le
fouet le joissains sauver une classe mon
ami la vapeur non mais c'est à dire que
sur x files qui avaient l'avancé de six
mois on peut le montrer peut-être alors
sur faux et fuit tout simplement e6 et
on voit que la tour est bien n'a plus
beaucoup de cas déjà voilà maintenant
les modèles un faux choix soit on monte
le roi soit ouais c'est ça bref quatre
menaces 3.5 celui de roger si c'est
l'option maliweb 7 avec une force et
dans donc en fait on est content de
donner un fou pour un pion à tous et oui
tout à fait c'est pour ça qu'on joue peu
fou et fuite parce que le duo pion est
trop forte donc à 5 et la rose catherine
entre le roi donc l'idée toujours c'est
de prendre aussi joué que 6 et ensuite
elle cède ce serait certainement ensuite
à 4 évident il faut très vite créer des
contre chance roy prend 1,5 à 3 très
vite attention la menace maintenant deux
ans après à deux on peut plus empêcher
de faire dame
donc il faut revenir et à voilà déjà un
petit repli donc d'où l'intérêt d'avoir
créé cette diversion le repli forcés
menacent évidemment faux prend 1,3 et en
cas de vado évidemment je vous fous des
deux contrôleurs la casse de promotion
et on a toujours quand même cet arrêt
lampions c'est pas aussi ce qu'elle
menace que c'est qu'elle est juste un
coup parce que si la belge et la lotion
reprises au taf et s'en pris la fessée
kg 5 qui vient compléter l'action
menaces qui avaient les pentes ou
récurrents fou et menacent également aux
six par la suite tafer ou fuite
maintenant il est temps de garder le
matériel que tout à l'offre n'a pas
voulu prendre alors en garde le matériel
et en même temps protéger croire donc
c'est bien vu quand même c'est assez
bien c'est bienvenue donc en quoi faut
pas rater le match quand on le voit
parce qu'après c'est ça devient très
difficile et va topalov danse dans cette
situation devait commencer à avoir des
petits regrets même si il est toujours à
l'optimisme c'était un genre très
optimiste il n'imaginait peut-être
encore gagné cette position mais aussi
ce médian comme j'ai dû rater quelque
chose qui se tramait temps c'est
celle-là sold out et attention aux
puisque attention maintenant le fou est
attaqué et voilà ça et c'est déjà très
difficile
puisque maintenant s'ils se foutant mais
bien le jura 3 vallées adam et ses deux
pions vont quand même avoir du mal à
passer face à fou fou est roi ça va être
un peu délicat à noter la pointe stephen
très importante c'est que sur 7
alors si on laisse aux huit dames mais
la menace d'armes reste donc floue
préemption et met tout simplement
prendre le pion un pion qu'on allait
prendre c'est trop prompt pour reprendre
maintenant menace toujours à deux donc
fou prend 1,3 à l'air en menaces à deux
parfaitement convenable il faut prendre
mais si la pointe ses tours aux trois
énormes grosse pointe puisque ça attaque
deux pièces ça récupère une pièce avec
en plus en plus s'appelle omnium et est
donc très certainement la partie gagnée
donc vous prend à 3 après fou prend à 3
il faut il faut il fallait ça défie le
faut il faut il faut il faut contre le
pion par dont les noires près d'ici et a
pris trois ou cinq tours ses hommes pour
ses reins donc là il ya une tour de plus
un pour d'options pas s'allier
donc c'est cbc beaucoup c'est beaucoup
même une tour de plus
d'autant plus que les pions en avant cet
incident a que ça on va voir la suite
tour c1 c'est assez normal on va essayer
de mettre la tour anglais ya quand même
pour des grosses tours de plus alors ça
quand même difficile et g5 toujours pour
topalov tout bref un os est tout un
symbole en échec en propre en descente
donc c'est de ces communes comme très
très grosse partie des fréquences par la
menace et e7 suivi de spidart évite donc
plus pro 7 est obligatoire il faut
prendre si on prend tout reprend ici on
peut encore se dire qu'il ya des bonnes
chances de nuls pour vesselin topalov on
sent qu'il a rien apprendre ce plan
voilà dans les médias des bonnes chances
dylan qui ont pour faire diversion il
faut que le cavalier arrive à prendre ce
plan des clés du roi ça paraît très
difficile
alors on va voir que quand même c'est
techniquement ça doit quand même être
gagnant pour les noirs ou et surtout de
venir tandis qu'il est assez précis dans
ce genre de situation surtout que il
comme il a eu très chaud
il a promis le rater quoi parce qu'il se
dit la suite du match va être dur ça va
être facile donc le roi des six attaques
tour bouge des cinq donc créé évidemment
une diversion centrale avec ce pion
maintenant roi et fuite cavaliers échec
3,8 très difficile de commenter une
finale dans l'est dans tous ses détails
d'autant plus qu'elle est très très
compliqué donc on peut pas vous l'aimez
avantage noir à vendre à juin voilà
cavaliers cheikh roi des huit cavaliers
ou six endroits ces huit pour éviter les
échecs et maintenant et kramnik veut
créer son contre jeu maintenant tôt ou
tard mais il faut pas qu'il fasse trop
tôt puisque si ce pion est prêt
disparaît et bien peu importe si les
blancs prennent celui-là roi cavaliers
contre roye tour et bien c'est nul et
noir peuvent toujours essayer de gagner
mais c'est nul
3e set et avec l'idée évidemment de
préparer nos cheminées pions ici donc il
veut jouer moins de six mois les 6-17 et
des vitres sur b 5e rue des six avec le
probable tout le prochain quinquennat je
crois que c'est la dernière faute de
total war kg semaine c'est le coût qui
al'air perdent en moyenne fatale aurait
dû revenir en d6 très certainement il
faut qu'ils gardent un oeil sur ce pion
qui sinon va devenir trop dangereux un
jour c'est ti s'éloigne un peu du pion
alors tant qu'il a la menace ça va mais
quand il l'a plus donc il ajouté moi
j'essaie kaiji singe pour éviter un il
voulait éviter tout simplement tourage
celle où amy si en fait c'est terminé
tout de suite et maintenant il ya des 5
voilà maintenant b5 et ça y est il faut
arrêter ce pion et on va voir que par
contre les noirs n'ont aucun aucune
peine arrêté ce pur avec une tour c'est
quand même très fort c'est très fort on
va le voir puisque après des six tout
simplement pour des biens tour des mains
voilà ça y est le groupe tuons est
contrôlé et on voit qu'il ne peut plus
avancer topaloff est ton t il
hier chose l'abeille de dédé avec son
cavalier et kallio 6 km es16 bkb 4
encaissés ça devient très difficile
maintenant
donc on me nathalie semaine pas je vais
17 malheureusement parce qu il a tenus
en échec
ça c'est très fort puisque maintenant le
roi est obligé de partir si ce qui se
passe avec 3,6 et là c'est fini le pion
ne pourra plus le roi est coupée le roi
est coupée donc ce pion ne peut plus ne
peut plus gagner ici a un coût donc tout
ça me donne un coup tous et de
l'entourer 3 voilà tout simplement ce
b38 roi est imparable et on va plus
pouvoir arrêter le pion il n'y a aucun
moyen pour les blancs des d'espions a
avancé puisque le roi et couper ici par
la cour
il pourra plus jamais revenu en jeu très
très belle quand même conclusion de
chroniques on va dire quand même que tu
en parles pas gâcher ses chances
maintenant si je joue comme ça
évidemment jusqu'à la fin du match il
peut très bien revenir il peut gagner
plusieurs parties kramnik peut être
fébrile parce que même s'il a gagné les
deux premières parties dont la première
partie a encore la limite il a tenu la
partie mais celle-là il est quand même
passé très très près de la
correctionnelle
c'était pas très près qu'il était
maintenant trois ou quatre roues enfin
c'était c'est spectaculaire
c'est celle qui s'est fait complètement
dominé y compris au niveau du choix
d'ouverture parce que je pense pas
toulalan oui tout une position quant à
où il se prend toutes les pièces à
l'attack donc je vois pour l'instant
pour moi celui qui a gagné les deux
premières parties c'est total of en
termes d'ouverture oui dans les deux cas
ils apprennent ici est meilleure avec
elle et avec les peut-être trop de
risques mais il a perdu deux parties
parce que kramnik est peut-être trop
solide aussi grave n'était pas évident
évidemment en phase aller chercher on
peut dire que ce café topalov
aujourd'hui c'est un peu comme vous
aussi au football mais ont raté un
penalty
un penalty et même mieux comme bennati
peut-être même un penalty à 3,3 m il ya
trois mètres des buts un écran mat un
match comme ça en trois coups qu'il a
pas qu'il a pas réussi à avoir terminé
pour cette pour cette 2e 2e partie tout
à fait exceptionnel qu'on avait pu voir
de ce championnat du monde kramnik
topalov qui va gagner ce championnat qui
va devenir le champion du monde unifié
il reste encore dix partis pour le
savoir pour le savoir à condition que
total of reviennent dans le match 6 7
tenir
ce camp à très bientôt sur des gonades
tv pour pour la suite et les analyses de
ce jeu plus riant